بالغاء الوجبات المجانيه وتخفيض التوظيف
حاليا تنوي شركه ابل اتباع سياسه جديده
لتفادي تسريح الموظفين وفقا لصحيفه وصف
جون الامريكيه ابل هي الوحيده تقريبا التي
مازالت صامده بين كبريات شركات
التكنولوجيا التي شهدت مؤخرا تصريحات
بالجمله للموظفين ولكن ابل ليست محصنه
بوجهه تحديات الاعمال التي اصابت عمالقه
التكنولوجيا الاخرين لان البيئه
الاقتصاديه المتقلبه احيانا لن ينجو منها
احد كما اشار طبعا الصحيفه الامريكيه
والخبراء يبقى السؤال لماذا بقيت ابل
محصنه حتى الساعه السريك من هنا مشاهدينا
بان شركه وظفت بمقدار بكثير من الشركات
الاخرى اثناء انتشار فايروس كورونا تحديدا
واليوم ستلجا الى السياسه نفسها بوابه
التاليه ستقلل الابد العدد الموظفين الجدد
وستسحب الامتيازات من هؤلاء الموظفين
الغاء ما يعرف بالوجبات المرجانيه التي
تقدمها الشركه للموظفين وهذا الامر
سيتزامن مع اعلان شركه ابل الشهر المقبل
عن اول انخفاض ربع سنوي في مبيعاتها منذ
اكثر من ثلاث سنوات لدى ابل مشاهدينا نحو
65000 موظف بيع بالتجزئه ويشكلون نحو 40%
من اجمالي القوى العامله في الشركه وفقا
لويس فوند جورد واما الشركات التكنولوجيه
الاخرى التي اصابتها الموجات وموجات تصريح
الموظفين فكانت اخرها الفا الشركه الام
لجوجل والتي صرحت موظفين على نطاق واسع مع
خطه الغاء نحو اثني عشر الف وظيفه قرار
شركه الفا بادجا بعد موجه من عمليات
التصريح الكبيره للعمال في امازون
ومايكروسوفت حيث شهد قطاع
صناعه التكنولوجيا تسريح اكثر من 200,000
عامل منذ بدايه عامه 2022
[موسيقى]